ce mardi 19 janvier vous auriez pu
entendre un léger bourdonnement est
maintenant de l'ancienne gare de la
grande ceinture
après plusieurs mois de travaux la ruche
de saint germain en laye a ouvert son
nouvel espace de coworking ou la ruche
de saint germain en laye à deux
activités principales
une première activité c'est du coworking
donc on accueille des gens qui viennent
travailler sur le lieu qui profitent de
tous les espaces qu'on a pensé comme un
parcours d'innovation pour développer
des projets autour du développement
durable et l'innovation sociale et puis
on a des programmes d'incubation qui
permettent à des entrepreneurs de
profiter d'un accompagnement sur 3 6 à 9
mois un accompagnement intensif pour
développer et accélérer leurs projets
c'est un essaim de 50 entrepreneurs déjà
rassemblés pour butiner dans un étage
divisé en cinq parties et suivant un
certain parcours espace café puis celle
de co création de partage de décisions
pour amener au dernier palier
et puis la dernière étape voilà pour
s'envoler en a imaginé une pique room
beaucoup plus grande qui permet de
développer ses idées auprès de
financeurs ou de d'associer potentiel
l'ellure aujourd'hui c'est premier étage
alors qu'auparavant on était uniquement
sur le rez de chaussée c'est vrai que
c'est assez agréable de découvrir ce
nouvel espace pour les élus partenaires
du projet l'emplacement de ce nouveau
centre d'activité n'a pas été laissé au
hasard et on voulait que ce lieu
s'implante au niveau de la la gare de la
grande ceinture qui est un lieu
historique emblématique de l'histoire de
la ville et qui retrouve dans un
quartier qui retrouve toute une nouvelle
dynamique et en développement puis
surtout le tram 13 qui est là dont les
travaux sont bientôt terminées et donc
voilà il faut à dos et l'activité
l'énergie à côté des moyens de transport
et des moyens de transports doux un
projet financé par plusieurs organismes
publics et privés à hauteur de 600 mille
euros en tant qu'acteur majeur de
développement économique